so hi everybody so my name is Chen Chen
I am a postdoc at Rutgers University so
it's very happy for me to be here
although I can't see you guys but you
know I'm happy to be here to talk to you
about function analysis of microbes and
the microbiome and their relationship to
the environment so I want to start from
this quote of dowing in his most famous
book so he says that I was must much
struck how entirely vague and AB tree is
the distinction between species and
varieties so basically what he says here
is that to give different organisms
different names correctly it's not easy
task so indeed if we look at this
example of four different birds living
on the same island you can see that they
bear to extend certain differences in
terms of their beaks and their head
according to the environment where they
living well however these differences
are subtle unless you an expert who are
varying to this specific kind of bird by
just looking at the picture it is not
very easy to tell like which one is
which and now imagine when we get down
to bacteria those tiny little bugs we
can't even see them so this issue
becomes even more complex so currently
the gold standard to tell whether two
bacteria of the same species or not is
using this technique which is called DNA
DNA have a hybridization so the idea is
that you take the DNA from both bacteria
you denature them into a single strand
and then mix them together and let them
real soci 8 and then you count the rate
of how much of this hetero stranded DNA
are there what is the fraction of those
and currently the current rule of thumb
is that if there are more than 70% then
you can safely say that these two
bacteria of the same species however
although this technique is very accurate
but it's experimentally very demanding
so
it is challenging that people start to
seek for another marker which is easier
to use and the answer that we have fun
this 16s RNA if you have been into this
field you must have heard about this
gene and it's always associated with a
magical number which is 97% sequence
identity so the rule of thumb is that if
two bacteria share more than 97%
sequence identity of their 16s RNA then
they are of the same species
it is quite widely known and practically
used in this field however it's just not
correct so what do I mean here so if you
look at this picture the x-axis is this
DNA hybridization rate and the y-axis is
a 16s RNA sequence identity and each dot
in this figure is a pair of organisms so
if we look at all the organism pairs
have less than 97% 16s RNA in sequence
identity we can see that you know
without an exception all of them belong
to different species but however if we
look at above 97% we both have the same
species organ in pairs as well as
different species opening pairs so this
rule of thumb is not really accurate in
reality so in order to quantify ok how
accurate it is really so here is
something that we did so we collected
the 1,400 bacterial genomes from NCBI
which covers the main domain of bacteria
and then I compared the 16s sequence
identity across every single pair of
these organisms and use that to predict
whether these two organisms of the same
species or not and the matter of the
performance based on different cutoff I
chose so for example if we use this
magic number of 97%
so for organism pairs that share
more than others mm presented anything
there are more than 55% of organisms
actually of different species and then
for those have less than 97% identity
actually more than 15% of them are of
the same species so what this is
basically is that if you're using that
famous rock thumb to identify two
bacteria to belong to the same species
using more than 97% of 16s RNA identity
then you are more than half of the time
will make a mistake so people started to
know this and then proposed that ok 97%
is not stringent enough that's to 98%
99% so but in reality here even if we
use a hundred percent just completely
identical 16s rRNA sequence it still
does not guarantee the two organism of
the same species the precision is
actually just about 75 percent like
three out of four are correct so by now
I hope that I have convinced you the 16s
RNA is not the best tool to use to
identify in species and this is just
example the hundred percent I identity
it doesn't really make powerful to buy
this so if we cannot use thickness RNA
then what can we use instead so we could
actually measure all of the different
features of certain bacteria for example
like its morphology physiology through
all those biochemical tests and then
just to find out all the details of what
a bacterium is like and then comparing
that to the other bacterium and see if
they are the same species I were asked
just you can tell from my description it
requires a lot of work and it's almost
impossible to measure everything so is
there a shortcut so the short catalyzing
the molecular function which is encoded
in the organism genomes which reflects
the morphology and physiology of that
bacterium
so if we were to use this function what
it could have function as a measure then
there are also some issues with it the
first thing is that a lot of the
proteins in bacterial genomes are not
yet annotated so here I collected the
same 1,400 bacteria is of the same data
set which contains four point two
million proteins so we can see that on
average about a third of those protein
and not annotated we don't know what a
function they perform and in some
organisms for example the one at the
very right it can be as high as more
than 80% of the protein in this
bacterium have no annotation at all we
have no clue what they are doing so yes
no annotation is the problem but now how
about those proteins that we do have
annotation with there is also another
problem which is missed annotation so in
this paper by external from 2009 so they
have shown that in the big basic public
databases like NCBI keg or swiss-prot
there's from 5% to 63% of missed
annotation in those database and this
number is really scary and it's more
scary that once the errors gets into
this database and stayed there it's very
hard to get them out and these error
just propagates to generate more errors
so it just make the situation worse and
worse but then why would we have this
miss annotation in the first place so
the culprit lies in the blind faith of
people in the homology by numbers so
what do I mean by that so if you have a
protein sequence with the unknown
function and you want to figure out what
this protein is doing so the most common
practice is that you just take it to
NCBI and you Blastoise you blast it
against some reference database and now
you look through the hits and find out
what this protein is doing so I give you
some example here so if you focus on the
first two lines here so you can see that
the blast eval you are very decent which
indicating that these proteins should
share the same function well in reality
they're actually not of the same
function so what I'm saying that there's
a function transfer by homology is not
always correct so is there another way
or a more reliable way to measure
whether two proteins of the same
function yes there is so this is
developed by the divisor of Maya divisor
which is so who is the doctor broker
roast in 2002 he established this
so-called HS SP metric so the idea is
that first of all you gather a bunch of
proteins from which their function
annotation I experimentally verified
which means that they are correct and we
can believe in them and then you do
pairwise alignments for all of them so
you end up with a pair of proteins like
an alignment of proteins of the same
function and you also have alignment of
proteins with different function and
then you map all of those alignments
into this 2d space of alignment men
against sequence identity and then you
train a curve to separate those same
lines or same function alignment from
the difference function alignment and
then once the curve is trained then
alignment above the curve will be
predicted to have the same function and
alignment a Beneatha curve will be
predicted to have different function and
the distance from the alignment to the
curve indicating the reliability of such
prediction so now with this new tool and
let's
the example that I just showed you guys
you can see that now if I calculate the
HS SP school of those two pairwise
alignment the HF SSP is correctly giving
me the information that is a minus value
which indicating that they of the
different function so the HS SP is a
more reliable way to measure whether two
proteins of the same function or not
than blast so with this too I was able
to actually calculate the h s SP score
for all of the pairs in 4.2 million
proteins and then I put all those 4.2
million proteins into this big network
so every two protein is connected by
their HS s peaceful or distance so in
this you can zoom that the proteins with
the similar function will cluster
together which I can identify later as
functional group a functional group
actually is protein clusters that
contain protein members sharing the same
function measured by H s SP so once I
have those so this is a flow chart of
the whole procedure so once I have
identified those protein clusters what I
can do is that I can map each bacteria
to a list of molecular functions that
its genome contains so for example both
the blue and the red bag has function
one and the function two and the
function 4 is unique to the red bag so
with this I can further calculate the
functional similarity between every pair
of bacteria by just comparing the
similarity between these function
lectures so if I use that similarity as
a new metric to identify if a to
bacteria of the same species or not here
you can see significant and obvious
performance skin comparing to using 16s
RNA
but however it's do not great because
you can still only retrieve like around
70% of precision so then what right so
we take the idea of like alright if the
pairwise alignment or the pairwise
comparison of bacteria does not really
work then let's try the network so now
we can actually put all of the bacteria
into a big Network and connect them by
the functional similarity in the same
notion the bacteria that are
functionally more similar tend to
cluster together as well so if I do this
to all the 1,400 bacteria in my dataset
we get a network somewhat like this like
a fish is a fish network so here in this
layout of the network all the organism
nodes are colored by the phyla and the
major classes so we can compare this
organism clustering to the taxonomy and
we can see that this network which we
call fusion so this fusion Network
actually reflects taxonomy but however
only to extent because here if I were to
use computational methods to identify
these explicit and the strong sub
Network within this fusion network by
saying sub Network I mean that the sub
network have very strong within network
connections and a very weak across I'm
sorry have very strong within sub
network connections and a very weak
across sub network connections so if I
were to identify these sub networks and
we can see that they do not entirely
overlap with the current exon so why
that the sub network is totally driven
by the function similarity but the
current economy is not because it is
somewhat arbitrary like what I mentioned
in the beginning by that one so I give
you
so at the top these two poor area
species they are functionally more than
99% identical but however they cause
different subtype of diseases and we
just decided to put them in two
different species and at the bottom
there's cross Trillium botulinum
strengths so they are functionally very
different less than 40 percent identical
from one another but however because
they all cause the same type of disease
we put them just in the same being in
the taxonomy so this is a very arbitrary
just like the bird example unless you're
an expert to spend your life studying
these specific bacteria you will not be
able to know what is going on and this
is actually also almost impossible made
it almost impossible to process like in
this large skew computational analysis
so I will leave an open question here so
do you think the current economy needs a
modification how would you address this
like contradiction here I would be happy
to hear your thoughts
so here I'll give you another example
showing like all right so how function
is affected by the environment so these
are this is a network of 40
cyanobacteria and I want you to focus on
the notes with the cyan ring those are
the Seneca cockers which is a genus of
cyanobacteria so you can see that those
marine sinico cockers are functionally
very different from the fresh waters
networkers and they are actually
functionally very similar to another
marine sign of bacteria which is the
properer cockers those are the ones the
not the nose with the yellow ring so
here we see a clear signal of how
microbial function is driven by
environments and the current economy is
not seeing cannot
see this change or this difference so in
order to make usage of our data we
beautif youjin DB which is the online
database which stores all of those 1,400
bacterial information that we calculated
function and environment information so
in Fusion DB we allow you actually to
submit your organism of interest submits
genome to us and then what we will do is
that we're gonna map it to the fusion
data so once the mapping is done you're
gonna see a result page like this so
first your organism will be mapped to
all the molecular functions that we
defined remember those protein
classrooms in the pig network so we're
gonna first map your organism into the
list of functions and then we will
calculate for the functional similarity
between your query organism against
every single reference organism in our
database and also as you can see here in
this picture each reference organism is
associated with environmental metadata
which includes like temperature oxygen
and habitat so you can further select
the organism of your interest and using
those and your Korea organism together
to create these network visualizations
on our database and you can color them
by economy by environments data to try
to find the patterns and why to find out
what is a reason to cause this function
similarity between these organisms so
that is so much of a genome
functional annotation and I will be
moving on to the microbiome so basically
microbiome is just the community of
bacteria that live in certain
environments so instead of looking at
one bug now we are looking at a group of
bugs so there are multiple ways to study
them but one
the most commonly used one is using
maritima which is the sequence all of
the genetic material from all of the
bugs in this environment and after that
we get these short fragments which we
call reads so there is one way to
assemble the reasoning to contact and
reconstruct the whole genome so I'm not
gonna talk about those today I'll be
talking about directly annotate function
from the reads so there are already some
resources dedicated to that for example
M G rest it's quite a famous one so it
annotates
the function directly from the reads so
how it does it so how does it do it so
it has a reference database contains
food and proteins with function
annotation and then it would just map
the reads to this reference proteins and
then if it's matches then the function
of the reference protein is transferred
to these reads but the problem with that
is because these are super short
alignments therefore you have a lot of
specific binding which means that you
end up with a lot of false positives and
another problem is again as I mentioned
before the annotation quality of the
reference database is questionable so
here you can see that the number so here
in this chart the bar on the very left
is the overall number of proteins in
swiss-prot the swiss-prot contains only
manually curated proteins manually
curated with proteins with functions and
manually curated and among all of those
how many proteins that we actually have
generated and see it in lab there's only
less than 6,000 proteins that we have
seen it in lab so that is the existence
evidence at the protein level so out of
a half a million around half a million
of the manually curated proteins only
6,000 proteins we have actually see the
protein the other ones we only know the
sequence we have met
the protein itself an amount is 6,000
proteins they are actually even a
smaller fraction which is more fewer
than 3,000 protein sequences whose
functions I actually experimentally
verified so we are talking about a very
tiny corset here that we have a high
confidence in their functional
annotation so we used this debt and what
we do is that we use the same idea to
train a curve to separate this same
function alignments from the different
function linemen however here the same
function are the Fung I'm sorry now
however here the alignments are not
protein-protein alignment anymore but
the short reads aligned to the fool ends
proteins and once we train the curve
that separates those same function
alignments from the different function
alignments same idea we can calculate
this now we call this new metric phasor
we can calculate this a phasor distance
which indicates the reliability of the
function predictions as well so we
compare the phasor to sight blast in
terms of the performance like how well
can we annotate functions so we can see
that the phaser outperforms sigh blast
eval you buy a lot with phaser you can
actually reach around 90% precision
which is amazing in terms of annotating
the short reads and we also created an
online service which is called my phaser
which is available at the website here
so in my phaser we accept your
submission of euro metagenomes and we
will annotate it for you using the
phaser algorithm against that gold
standard database where every single
protein or every single protein is
functional annotation is experimentally
verified so once your job is processed
the result looks something like this so
on the top
there are some statistics and
descriptions of the job and the bottom
is the read abundance table so you have
like each line indicates one function so
here all the functions are reliable
because they are experimentally verified
and then you have the number of reads
that mapped to this function so the idea
is with my phaser we can turn your
metagenomes into functional profiles
looks like this and from there we can do
actually a lot of different analyses so
I'm gonna give you some examples of what
we have done on different samples the
first one I want to show you here is
actually the based on the BP oil spill
sent data so I'm sure you heard about
this it's been Asti but however for this
group they actually had the same data
before you during all your face and then
have the same sample like after the oil
has been degree and being degraded so
the post all your face so we analyze
this data set with my phaser and I use
MDS which is a polarization method to
compare the functional similarity
between these metagenomes
in the data set so you can see it's
actually pretty well separated between
different faces but what is more
interesting here is actually you can see
that this from the priori to all your
face and then to post all your face it's
kind of showing the sand microbial
community is recovering from this
contamination and another example I'm
showing you here are human data so which
is there are two patients with Crohn's
disease and their healthy relatives so
what you can see here is that for these
two patients so we have their gut
microbiome samples so their gut
microbiome actually functionally very
different from their healthy relatives
and which is more interesting is that
even between these two patient
gut microbiome functions are also very
different which indicate the possible
which indicate the possible different
mechanism of the Crone disease as a
genus T or how that reacts with that's
microbe and so on and this is also sorry
so this is also done by MDS so from our
experience MDS
this realization method is very good for
small sample size however for big sample
size like testing banning is more
suitable so what I'm showing you here
the last example is that these are from
the City subways the microphones are
sampled from the City subways from
various cities from the world okay so
for example the green ones in this chart
sampled from subways in New York City
and then the cyan ones are so sampled
from Porto and then the pink ones the
magenta ones assembled from Tokyo right
so what you can see is that there is a
high functional similar dissimilarity
for the New York City samples they
actually scatter around and just
everywhere but however if you look at
the Porto sample and Tokyo sample they
are functionally more consistent to each
other so there are a lot of interesting
that you can do with this because I'm
out of time I will not go into any
further so here I want to give some
credits and acknowledgments to people
who are also behind this so dr. Malak
Yannick Mallik which is on the bottom
left corner so he is also a co-author of
the fusion DB and dr. max Miller which
is the guy in the middle on the top so
he is a co-author and also for the my
fate sir so we are now currently
updating these two tools so if you have
any idea or any suggestions please feel
free to shoot me an email
I'll be very happy to hear them and on
the right is a lab so on top is the
adviser
avianna Bromberg and
we have our laminates so thank you very
much